this times coming up and I'm showcasing
and I'm do my act and Duncan Trussell
called me and he told me the three rules
for showcasing for Mitzi yeah which was
do joke about your ethnic group do joke
about one of your parents and then do
your favorite joke
so I did joke about my mom power walking
in LA going to the beach take your shirt
off baby start crying you know because
we're so free yeah I did a bit about
Asians on ecstasy which is a classic
because you guys are so smart you drop
[ __ ] ecstasy your visuals are much
better
don't be digitally sounded a joke right
I might bring it back every right old
jokes cause they're bad same access that
dim isn't so I go up to do my act and I
see who sits down it's Paul Mooney and
I'm like [ __ ] you just do the act and
get done dude yeah so I get offstage and
I walk up this is true so I she goes it
turns out Paul Mooney likes my he liked
me a lot yeah and he sat down so Mitzi
this kids good you got to pick him up he
needs to be a regular here and I was
like holy [ __ ]
so I go up to her and I'm like Mitzi
because you already had kissed you
always had to kiss the ring so I go I go
Mitzi thank you for the choking she's
like you're really funny
she goes are you Syrian and I hand to
God I didn't know what the [ __ ] a Syrian
was yeah yeah I'm from upstate New York
public educated yeah we never gotten to
the Syrian stuff yeah sounds like
someone who loves Sears that's why I
didn't know what the [ __ ] it was yeah
yeah right yeah so she goes are you
Syrian I'm like yeah I'm totally serious
yeah yeah she's like okay good she's
that good I want you to do a showcase
and for Jay Dave and Jay Davis's show
she said cuz people don't realize Jay
Davis like how big that Dublin show was
way back in the day like it was Andheri
it was nothing like anyone's ever seen
you'll never have anything like it
because now you could play all that I
mean let me just say this okay it says
that on Tuesday nights
Jay Davis and I met a man had this room
called Dublin's was an Irish bar
in between the Laugh Factory in the
comedy store across the street and on
we're pink taco Rio so so that night
it's like say Miami Beach Club that's
never open to anything I yeah it's so
it's so weird yeah but now imagine
absurd what I would have fit 250 maybe
yeah 300 was like under people rights
likes little smaller than the main room
number one every Tuesday sold out number
to you it was like you would go look in
the audience oh there's Britney Spears
Cameron Diaz I mean everyone either
every you would go you would perform and
then you would just get business cards I
remember that's the first time that Dave
Becky actually recognized me is a real
comedian like he walked it to me goes
bro you're legit you know man I go oh he
goes too bad with Abby I love Abby you
know me but if you weren't yeah I mean
you know I mean I would you know it was
like one up but it was like one of those
events where every comic wanted to get
on you announced yourself yeah like
every week I remember going there and
there was a new gunslinger yeah like I
remember seeing Reap they're like yeah
you kill there yeah and a new dude next
week what the and over and over you see
Pablo they're Francisco destroy yeah you
would stain it was the King there you go
on stage and for like a brief second you
were on these levels of these
supermodels that's why I get off stage
and girls so far out of my league we're
like you were so funny yeah they're
talked to me because they saw me on
stage everybody there thought I was the
coke dealer girls come up to me like
we're we're looking for coke I'm like
[ __ ] man I should get Co yeah this is
also like I remember one night Larry
David went up this is before the
original Kirby enthusiasm in between
Seinfeld and curb he was she stupid want
to get on there too I mean it was like
one of those magical places dude I saw
Bill Maher there yeah he's like this is
the best room I've ever seen that
[ __ ] like Vince Vaughn would go up
I'll go up yeah that's how that was back
back in the day so did it just fizzle
out over time no what happened was
Dublin's closed what happened was that
the Lakers right this is one
Lakers Shack and Kobes were like killing
in the NBA and the [ __ ] Hollywood
strip got really ghetto dude it's like I
remember just I would go to the store
and there would be like right down the
center of Sunset would be like 20 cop
cars just just waiting for [ __ ] to go
down yeah and it's just like that's what
killed sunset yeah like it used to be
insanely packed and now it's kind of
like Hollywood Boulevard but now even
that is I think it's gone downtown now
this is one fat Tuesdays on Tuesday you
couldn't even go to the comedy store it
was like you're in Detroit you were in
Atlanta Yeah right I mean it was like
you pee in the [ __ ] patio and you're
a gun one night a good right
worthy Patterson my first manager he
grabbed him by the back of the head and
he just put me underneath like a table I
thought like Wesley not really saved my
life that night you know it was that
[ __ ] crazy back then yeah I mean it
was I mean it's crazy now I mean imagine
him showing up like that oh yeah oh my
god you would have died there's a
president of white people
[Laughter]
[Music]